uk gdp growth is expected to slow
sharply over the first half of the
forecast period
that predominantly reflects the
significant adverse impact of the sharp
rises in global energy and tradable
goods prices on most uk households real
incomes
it is a measure of the scale of the
shock
that total real household disposal
income is projected to fall by one and
three-quarter percent in this 2022 which
apart from 2011 would be the largest
contraction since comparable records
began
in 1964.
and i must say that i recognize the
hardship this will cause for many people
in the uk
particularly those on the lowest incomes
often with little or no savings who are
hit hardest by increases in the prices
of basic necessities like food and
energy
as a result of the associated decline in
activity
although the unemployment rate is likely
to fall further in the near term to
three point six percent in q2
it is projected to rise to five and a
half percent in three years time given
the sharp slowdown in activity
with monetary policy acting to ensure
that longer-term inflation expectations
are anchored at the two percent target
upward pressure on cpi inflation is
therefore expected to dissipate over
time
global commodity prices are assumed to
be consistent with the conditioning
parts for energy prices and so rise no
further in the central projection
global bottlenecks are expected to ease
over time
and the weakening and growth and
building excess supply leads domestic
inflationary pressures to subside